let me be a bit more specific so ross
was referring to cataclysm as one of the
reasons for why the aliens i don't know
if they should be called aliens but
those from the future may come back into
the past
i i don't know i i really like ross i i
i think he is a deep thinker um
i really enjoy talking to him actually
even about these subjects and and
throwing conjecture against the wall
but i find myself um having a really
hard time saying what are we i mean not
to
not to play games but what are we
talking about here because
if we're talking about climatology or if
we're talking about uh
as we said sedimentary record and other
things like that of what has happened
before
we're throwing in aliens that we can't
prove we're throwing in a historical
record that's spotty
i agree that some of these things when
placed on the table together make a
certain amount of sense but i can't say
that the things we're placing on the
table make sense by themselves
and so there's a great deal of
conflation going on and i don't want to
say that anyone's using their
imagination too much but
i i think that it would just be my
opinion about
a lot of fiction and conjecture that
i've taken in over the years
which doesn't really apply
um in any way shape or form the work i'm
doing right now so it's
it's imaginative and i think it's
interesting
but
again i can't i couldn't get there as an
investigator
because i'm i'm making to an extent
making up one of the
um
one of the suspects
and i'm i'm assuming a story of one of
the complainants
to arrive to say that a crime has
occurred
it's the fruits of the poisonous tree so
it's it's
um if we had like a show about
conjecture and we wanted to really dig
into that you know we can get some
graham hancock or another expert maybe
from one of the ancient uh ancient
architect channels or something like
that i think we could have a really
interesting conversation but it just uh
it doesn't apply other than to my
opinion
sure i'll go also i'll add you know my
concern is right now let's just say
hypothetically we as a species right now
we have the ability to go back in time
my concern is the whole paradox issue
right you know there's a saying if i go
back and i kill my grandfather well then
i don't exist and so therefore i
couldn't go back in time to kill my
grandfather so
there's a paradox issue here and if
there's a species that that is for some
reason or us let's say coming back from
a future and i don't want to say the
future because we don't know if there is
you know the or perhaps a or multiple um
the bottom line is that if you if you
come back and interfere with the past
you may very well inadvertently affect
your ability to exist in the future and
change things irrevocably and in fact
you may change things for the worse not
the better so
you know i i think it's certainly
interesting to speculate but you know i
i think that's why
it's it's tough for us to to conceive
about going backwards in time i think we
can slow down enough the relativity time
can be slowed down
and it can be potentially even stopped
to some degree but
but to go backwards is a little bit
different you know you're asking the
river to run backwards and you can slow
it you can dam it up but to have a river
go backwards it's a little more more
tough than that
and so there lies the conundrum um you
know if if you go the mere fact that you
go back in time you know let's say
hypothetically to your time period which
is what would matter if you went back in
time you wouldn't want to go back to
some other
you know other parallel universes time
because you're not going to affect your
your own
your own your own paradigm so you know
you have to take take it with a grain of
salt and i'm not sure
that
um i'm not sure we would want to do that
because of the risk that you you would
have to to and then you have the
question about matter in the universe
right so if i take matter from the
future
and the universe has only x amount of
matter x amount of energy and matter
can't and energy can't be created
destroyed now i add more matter how
how does that affect the rest does it
perturb the the existing model of the
universe by the mere factor introducing
more matter into a universe that only
has x matter you know and how does that
occur and now does that initiate another
potential big bang you know these are
the questions you have to ask yourself
seriously
whenever you
you're you're you know
providing a theory about time travel um
again it's what like sean said it's fun
to speculate but
there's a lot more considerations that
one has to consider if if that was
really possible and would you really
want to do it
quick editor's quiddity here for those
interested in the details a positive
cosmological constant allows for the
creation of energy and energy seems to
only locally be conserved not globally i
think the the we can all take the scene
from um
one of the avengers movies and it goes
end game where they you know they ran
through all of the
all the different time travel movies
and they were trying to explain you know
they're all they're all wrong you know
they're getting it wrong
and they started talking about real
physics and the possibility of alternate
realities and alternate dimensions and
things like that but we have to ask
ourselves again if we don't have any
personal perception of that if we can't
detect it
um again assigning motive
is very um
very much just opinionated opinion
weaving you know
i don't even know if i have a time
machine or if there's an alien what his
motive is what he wants
and agreed with lou again what are even
the mechanics of operating something
like i don't know you know it's it's far
beyond my ken
and just so you know lou you mentioned
at one point that the present is thick
for lack of a better word cigarette
burning as the analogy and for people
who are interested in a more
mathematical treatment of that i spoke
to someone named nicholas jason who gave
a formalism to indicate that the present
time is thick that you can't pick out a
particular point that as soon as you do
it's almost like honey so if you're
interested in that i'll put a link in
the description yeah no and we see that
very practically in in the world of of
of quantum physics and even the the the
expression or the description of an
electron you know again we
for for your audience who's probably my
age remembers in high school you learn
that an electron orbits uh the nucleus
of an atom but in reality that's not
what's occurring we now realize it's
it's called an electron cloud for a
reason because of predictability and the
fact that the electron can never be
isolated in a fixed position
um you can't do it and in fact is some
scientists now are speculating that it
is because the electron
uh is is is everywhere and nowhere at
the same time it is it is so small that
it may literally be zipping in and out
through the very fabric of space-time
uh and so it's nonsensical to to to try
to predict the position of an electron
because
there is no position it's it's
everywhere and nowhere at the same time
around the nucleus of an atom and um you
know that's that's that's some of the
the observations we're beginning to see
now and let me add to that that the past
and the future are human semantic
constructs
it is always now it always has been now
from the universe's perspective
um the past is not something that's
sitting next door to us
um it's
so
in another way people think of things
and we think when we say that the stars
are very far away the light took a very
long time to travel to us we're seeing
the past again that's a metaphor we're
not seeing the past we're seeing now and
now as those photons are here hitting
your eyes where at one point they were
not
and so these are arbitrary concepts a
lot of times so we've applied a linear
understanding to to something that
exists on a much deeper much deeper
spectrum
in a lot of ways
when we talk about going past going
future and i think a lot of what lou's
talking about is that reality is
anchored in now
and in the present and in the the
entropic state that we exist in at this
moment
and so there's so many variables to that
and we've jumped we're jumping to motive
you know i i think that's that's
something we just have to keep in mind
yeah i'll go even a step further kurt
too with that
kind of piggy backing off of what what
sean said you know the whole notion of
of here and now
is is almost nonsensical um it's it's
let me give an example i ask you kurt
where are you where are you right now
let's do a little quick exercise uh for
you and your audience where are you
right now kurt
[Music]
let's say toronto
canada okay where's toronto where where
is toronto i don't know how to answer
that
okay well where where's where's where's
canada
where's norway
yeah right
right and where's where's our solar
system
where's our milky way
there is no here here okay we we invent
here because we have to live in an
environment where we are used to
boundaries and borders in order for us
for things to make sense but in reality
the big scale of things in the scale of
the universe
the notion of here and now is really
nonsensical because depend depends on
where i am relative to everything else
here
go ahead sean sorry it's like trying to
pick out a specific electron from the
electron cloud
it's it's um
yeah it's it's
everything is moving
so dynamically
at all times that that a a location is
is not a concept it's only a locate it's
only a location in a in a certain
regional area
and you have to have some kind of
substrate to measure that against
and we live in a universe that lacks a
substrate there's no snap to grid that
we can say we've you know we've we're
now 14 parsecs northeast to
you know
local global or cluster north what is
what's that mean
you know how would you navigate to that
um
that that's something that really that
really digs into my head how would we
navigate to a point in the past you have
to figure out its location in space time
[Music]
we haven't found space time yet to be a
thing to measure in that way
and in fact you know if you look at in
the
the theory of of of
of inflation of the universe during the
big bang early parts of the big bang and
even now as the expansion of the
universe continues to get bigger and
faster you know scientists are now now
stating that space itself is space time
itself is is being created and that's
how you have this this expansion of the
universe occurring faster and faster and
faster
uh and that's you know when you when you
when you look at that case in point let
me let me see if i can if i can bring
this to a little bit easier to
understand um the the universe has been
estimated to be almost not quite 14
billion years old right and yet when you
ask the scientists how big is our
visible universe from end to end they
say it's about
94 billion light years across well how
can that be because that means the
universe has to be expanding bit faster
than the speed of light well
not necessarily what's happening
in in theory is that actual space-time
itself is expanding as well
um think of uh probably the best way to
explain it would be imagine um
water seeping up from the bottom of the
bathtub and filling up the bathtub it's
filling up from all sorts of little
pores water's coming out everywhere not
just out of the spigot but everywhere
it's starting to fill up the tub
if that is the case then
then
again the notion back to where we are in
the universe is always changing in fact
when when you say to yourself and it's a
little bit scary to do but you say i'll
be here tomorrow no you won't you will
never be here again and you you can't
it's impossible because the the the
entire universe isn't static it's moving
and the only way to know where you are
is only relative to other people and
where they are and by the way are they
just as lost as we are so and i don't
mean that just figuratively i mean that
physically you know we we are all kind
of
kind of scattered through the winds
together and the only way we can kind of
relate to each other is oh you're you're
you're kind of close to me so i guess
relative you know you're you're six foot
and i'm five foot
you know nine and and and we gauge
things relative to each other but we
really have no idea
where we really are or even when we are
and that's
you know something to to ponder perhaps
we invented time so we know when to meet
for lunch tomorrow but in reality we
just observe entropy